scheduled
Live Well gentle fans of the channel
welcome to
Sidra today we will be debating the
wisdom how Amazon GM Kickstart the new
Stargate franchise what kind of
production should they be starting we
have two contestants
two we have Jamie and Harris jimie is
somewhere too close to Wales and Stoner
Harris will be supporting the position
of movies first someplace from Southern
[Music]
California crazy Jamie will be uh he
will be supporting The Stance of
Stargate should start with a series
he'll be bold fisted about this
position and then
Harris movie first lad lad he will be
movies first he'll be challenging
Jim's opinions and ideas and
philosophies about how the series should
take precedence I'm in the middle so
these two won't actually come to
blows and across the Pacific I think do
what said my arm can reach across the
Pacific watch out yeah but you're
smartass
can roll the
[Music]
introduction this is SM so we will be
debating what is best to kick off the
franchise we have four primary questions
each contestant will answer that
question and then at the very end we
have a lightning round of other
questions with mega nerd questions an
ultra nerd question and a possible
tiebreaker question in the
end
so Jamie you look frustrated I'm nervous
I didn't know there was gonna be oh
nervous okay so um let's get on with the
show questions or Harris do you need
more prep time to back up your
philosophy oh I've been backed up
statements open his statements opening
statements okay so we will start with
Jamie well here's the qu here's the
question and we'll hear from Jamie first
Harris will say something smarty maybe
in a recent poll
stop what opening statement I wrote an
opening State oh you have an opening
statement well since there is now
opening
statements let's hear from Jam's opening
statements before he gets closer to
Welles I'm not Jamie don't you have an
opening statement get to it man Matthew
this is going very
well there thank you so each person I'm
I'm I'm in control now so
my opening statement the the sleeping
giant of sci-fi is Awakening we've been
talking about it for two years now but
what has changed for the giant while
it's been
asleep so much time has gone by and we
don't know what has happened a movie
simply cannot tell us everything that we
need to
[Music]
know I'm being distracted by noises so
I'm GNA think so where are the Jaffa now
how is the Jaffa Nation developing and
growing where is the Lucian Alliance are
they still being a complete pain in the
ass what about the evil Ewoks are we
ever going to get to see them there are
so many things that we just don't know
that a two-hour movie can't give us and
can't tell
us sg1 took
us from nothing to having our own Fleet
within 10 years more time than that has
gone by by we could have gone even
further what is happening on Earth is
any of that technology that we've been
giving to random people all over the
universe actually leaked out into our
own planet is the Stargate still a
secret there are so many things we need
to know and we just don't a 2hour movie
will not scratch the surface but a
series 10 hours more now that could tell
us everything we need to know and set up
for a bright future of St Target a movie
is a massive risk a series is a Sure
Fire home run and it's as simple as
that you didn't say series is a home run
about the rings of power just saying
Harris do you have an opening
statement do I so the sleeping giant of
sci-fi has been asleep for a long time
now and would you rather wake it up with
a slow crawl would you rather wake it up
with a cup of coffee hit in the ground
running and actually putting some
momentum into a project that has been
asleep for far too long something that
needs a little life brought into it and
is the best way to do that TV which is
we're we're out of our the golden major
TV right now that was 2013 through about
2021 2022 we're at the tail end of
that is is TV really the right place
that we want to be or or do we want
something I I was in the shower this
morning as as you think you know best
place to think I was listening to Lord
of the Rings and Stargate soundtrack why
can't we have Stargate on on Lord of the
Rings scale-wise not rings of power
scale-wise but Lord of the Rings
scale-wise why
not alrighty good deal I think the
Golden Age of Television ended somewhere
in the 70s with the Advent of cable not
in 2013 but that's just just
me all right so are we ready to get with
the questions Jamie can you put it off
any longer no go for it
okay so again the questions we have four
questions they are for the over for the
overall debate Amazon MGM should kick
off with a franchise kick off the
franchise the new franchise the new
Stargate franchise with a movie or a
series which so I'll start with Jamie
first with the first question and then
I'll move to Harris so here's the
question for both of in a recent poll
93% of Sid Trek viewers voted for a
series first shouldn't Amazon just do
what the audience wants Jamie
please Matthew went for a walk but he's
back now no Matthew I'd already done it
because you's gone for a walk thank you
sorry Matthew is in the background doing
the production stay sat down egit
Anyway Amazon is a business first and
foremost that's what they do they
started their business by delivering
what the customer wants and delivering
it quickly and basically saying anything
that you want we will deliver to your
door next day they have basically
destroyed the High Street because they
were so damn good it they know that the
customer is always right and that is the
core of their philosophy and when 93% of
your customers say they want a product
you deliver it that's what Amazon does
when almost none of the customers want a
movie you don't risk a100 million doar
on something nobody wants the cinema is
to say the least a risky Affair at the
moment so why would you risk it it comes
down to spending twice as much money on
a 2hour product that nobody wants or
spend half the money on 10 hours that
your customers actually want
93% is not a slight Victory it's an
absolute Landslide and
anybody that thinks a movie is a good
idea is a complete [__] and now he is a
Texan so I might get shot for that but
it's just it's just true
93% you you can't argue with
that well well Harris that was kind of a
strong statement for the series he he he
included the history of Amazon the
capitalistic brutality of its owner Jeff
Bezos so Harris what would you have to
say about a movie starting off the
Revival of
Stargate H
go sometimes we think about things
through some Rosy tinted
glasses and sometimes we think about the
future of both Stargate and the
franchise that we want to keep moving
here we can think about it in the Rosy
tent with the we want we want we want
but what do we need are are we children
with want in a candy shop or we actually
thinking about what's best for the
franchise what's best for the IP what's
best for Brad Wright in general what's
best for all of us as
fans if we do a series it doesn't mean
if we do a movie it does not mean there
will be no series coming that that's the
best part about the movie you do the
movie you have the set ready for the
series it pre- does everything that you
need to set up for a series so so you
still get it one way or another it's not
a want versus
need look look at look at the need and
look at what we want as a franchise as a
whole and then you can kind of put it
into
a a movie Just does more I guess uh at
the end of the day we can put it into
the the sense of if you have a movie you
have everything that you have set up
already for this TV series and you have
the ability to go gain a new audience
that wasn't there before that might be
in one way or another the series is
going to happen and if the movie does
fail because that's the big thing if it
fails oh we might not get Stargate BS if
they're putting star together they're
going to get a movie and a series
together one way or another and if the
movie quote unquote fails hey then we
got MGM plus and a cheaper TV series
that's going to feel something more like
the original series anyway is that a
win-win or a lose lose I think it's a
win-win either way and if the movie does
succeed which I very much think it would
because all of us every single Le person
watching this will'll put their ass in a
seat for that movie we'll probably bring
our families we'll probably bring our
friends etc etc etc we're going to still
watch the series after the fact but that
movie will give them money that gives
them that gives them a knowhow that
gives them what we want what we know
what it it allows them yes the World
building might be a little difficult
with it but within those two hours you
can actually put a little more simple
something together and have it where you
don't need to overc convolute something
you can just have it simple sometimes
you know my favorite saying is keep it
simple stupid so I'm saying keep it
simple stupid give us meat meat and
bones we don't need all the fat on the
on the movie give us two hours of
goodness two and a half hours of
goodness hell give me that Lord of the
Rings three hours epic if it's goodness
as long as there's not too much fat give
me the meat give me the muscle give me
the bones and that leads him to the
series oh okay all right well Harris
made some strong points let's see if if
we have any if we could run a poll maybe
in the chat to see how Harris did did he
inspire you to Greatness or did he uh do
a belly flop and now we've got Matt take
away
Matt no okay all
right no mat okay are we going to have
two minutes and debate the question
well I thought we would at least have a
uh a rebuttal period so uh Jamie this
would be your I mean I know this W
discussed previously but I think Jamie
would deserve a rebuttal and uh so would
Harris deserve a
rebuttal so I did do a poll I did do a
poll I did do a oh oh thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you uh so
the entire thing I can't solo myself I
don't know why so I'm just going to
appear like this
whatever halfway through that Jay was
winning for 56% and J and Harris was on
like 30% but then halfway through
Harris's statement it's shot
up um it's now evened out Jay still won
with
56% I consider Harris got Harris has got
44% so it's quite it's quite an even
split but for the for the longest time
Harris you were losing for a long time
until you did I think halfway through
your speech people obviously just
connected with it and just like yes
haris yes
haris second sometimes we get there with
a 56% majority as they would say in
Florida that's plainly a
loss oh oh that's say that okay so so uh
let's go
to I don't oh my God I don't know what's
going on so okay so if we Let's
uh Jamie let's have your uh rebuttal
please Harris you on more than one
occasion said
need and that we need so are you
seriously suggesting for one Amazon
knows better than the customer so you're
telling me that Amazon knows what I need
better than I do for one but for two
that we need a movie rather than a
series what are you basing that
on
Oh I thought we were going two minutes
two minutes no no no period so we can
argue all right you well well
I say that again sorry I I was getting
the whole whole thing together mentally
there I Was preparing my rebuttal
rebuttal you said Matt you can just keep
storming in the middle during the
rebuttal period sorry guys we're trying
to figure this out but we're we we've
never done this sort of format before
so I'll explain again idiot um that
some point um you said repeatedly that
we need the movie for one why do you
think that Amazon knows what we need
better than we do oh that's right I got
your thing Amazon's freaking Amazon
they've had all of us under an algorithm
for the past two decades before we knew
what an algorithm was they know what we
want and what we need more than we ever
do and that's just based on the products
we buy from them that's to bring back I
guess the the capitalistic Bezos remarks
and stuff like that from the beginning
he understands us whether we like it or
not he understands us rings of power big
mishap it happens but Stargate is
something that they have decided because
of rings of power that it's something
that they need to be delicate about
they've they've taken time to actually
think about what's best for this what's
right and what's right if it was a
series we would have had a series two
years ago that's what they've been
inviting about own MGM two years ago
it's been two years they bought it in 20
21 right no oh no it was towards the end
of 21 but then it took like nine months
to go through that's the end of 2 just
over a year okay but anyway that's
irrelevant so you say that that's what
we need 93% of the population say we
want a serus so surely that's what we
need want versus need that that
childlike Rosy tin and glasses is really
easy you're in a candy store with your
parents what are you going to say you
want versus what you need if you need
something it might be the candied apple
you know like okay you got a nice Apple
but you know what you're going to go
right to that toffee you're going to go
right to that like pie in the corner
it's what you want versus what you need
have a little something in the middle
because one way or another that movie
sets up the series so it's not negating
the series at all whatsoever and it
allows you to come in there with a
little momentum with a little hoods spa
and that's what we need 30 seconds
remaining what's better a nice chocolate
bar or an apple what's better you your
health Cy Apple candy apple it's what
you want not what you need you need the
Apple but you want the candid Apple no I
don't
I Snickers kind of pink Snickers for a
candy apple one way or another it needs
to be a little it's not necessarily the
best flavorful thing at the first the
thing you think of at first but it's all
right there we go finally that's over
with candy apple so somehow we went from
Jeff bezos's angry capitalism to candy
and apples in one
round so now we go on to question two
are you guys ready for question two oh
yes all right so we're gonna start with
Harris this time here's the question for
both of you Cinema is still the most
prestigious way to restart a franchise
anything less shows Amazon lacks
confidence in Stargate
Parr can I just repeat the question and
and call it I'm kidding I'm joking I
don't actually need the question
repeated the question repeated would
exactly be my answer though Cinema is
prestigious at the moment where there is
prestige TV it's becoming a little more
hit or miss where at one point there was
House of the dragon and and not excuse
me there was Game of Thrones before that
and there were these other things there
were there were Vikings there was
uh uh Westworld another HBO thing Etc
now Marvel was going to do a bunch uh
Marvel and Disney and Lucas film in
general were doing a bunch of prestige
television with the MCU with Star Wars
and stuff like that within a couple
years that went to to nothing it went to
God awfulness pretty quickly so I I
think that prestige in cinema is still
pretty freaking evident in in front of
all of us there's a reason barbin Heimer
did so well this year that that was
prestigious and and those were two tin
pole films for this
Studio Stargate is a tin pole film and
Tin pole IP for Amazon Prime and MGM
Studios that's what we need is it is it
a lack of confidence to not have it not
necessarily so I will pivot a little bit
there and say it's not necessarily a
lack of confidence that makes it where
oh well we're gonna put a movie out in
front of a series but it it shows their
confidence if they do right all right so
Jamie me did need me to re uh restate
the question or the comment no
okay it's oldfashioned I think to say
that the cinema is still the prestigious
thing that it was even 10 years ago
because it's not anymore it's not the
same as it was I mean it was already in
Decline before coid but since coid it
has been decimated Cinema needs to
completely refind itself like it did in
the '90s back when the video shop
exploded loaded and Cinemas closed left
right and Center it needs to figure out
itself again now is not the time to take
anything that you consider to be pentle
pent tle
pentle um to the cinema also the the
world the lines
between um Cinema and TV have been being
blurred for the last 10 years it's not
the same as it used to be movie stars
appear in TV I'm watching a brilliant
show at the moment with Sylvester
Stallone on Paramount that is as good a
quality as anything we get at the cinema
um I watch shows like slow horses even
if you don't like rings of power you at
least have to appreciate the quality we
get things like foundation and so on and
so on that these things are and would
not look out of place on a big
screen peard season 3 had couple of
episodes that they actually blew up in
IMAX and showed them in Cinemas because
they were such good quality and so loved
that people wanted to see him on that
format the cinema is not the thing it
used to be Ethan Hunt found it
impossible to get people in the cinema
to watch his movie and Indiana Jones
fell on his ass immediately Barbie and
Oppenheimer were big hits but they
weren't expected to be nobody really
knows what is going to be a hit or a
failure at the cinema at the moment and
that is why it's just way too big a risk
to take something like Stargate there
but even if it wasn't a big risk it's
not necessary anymore streaming services
want subscribers and subscribers will
follow something new and exciting and
that's why Stargate should do a series
because it will draw subscribers to MGM
and power and and Amazon even and that's
why it's just not necessary and it's too
big a
risk
do you have a rebuttal oh but of
course rebut
[Music]
away I think you proved your own point
and my point by saying peard was put in
theaters so is Ahsoka look how that
turned
out it doesn't necessarily mean that
this prestigious TV is going to be on
the same level as a film one way or
another like like the the budget does
not equal quality per se and I think
that's what you're kind of hinting at
and that's not the case the Creator just
came out and it's taking a little bit to
make its back take it to make its money
back but on an80 million budget it
created an epic that Stargate could
follow in easily in that same vein we're
we're very much uh thinking about it
through just a Fan's eyes you got to
look at it through an executive's eyes
just just a little bit there the the
series there is no way to make money on
the series at the beginning if you're
thinking about subscribers everyone that
wants to be subscribed to MGM or Amazon
Prime for Stargate is already
subscribed no no no no no no no no no no
rebuttal rebuttal sure go for it we are
going through an economic crisis we are
going through a period where people have
gone from having on average four
subscription services on streamer
services to
1.8 that generally one or two streamer
Services we're going into a period where
Amazon Apple Netflix are going to having
to scrap for the subscribers they've got
never mind
growing so 100% right now the streaming
services way more than even 18 months
ago desperately need big content that's
going to draw subscribers to them or at
very least keep the subscribers they've
got and a movie that then goes onto
Amazon Prime ain't going to do that I
think you forget that Amazon Prime is
Amazon Prime and they're going to have
just as many subscribers or very up next
close to just as many subscribers
Netflix will always have just because
they're Amazon Prime and people are
already paying for Amazon Prime itself
they get the service of prime because of
that that one or two streaming services
it might be their one favorite and that
second one is always going to be Amazon
Prime maybe not always but 99 n out of
10 it's going to be Amazon Prime one way
or
another from from where that's
distracting that
um see even the internet hates you right
now haris that was they typed that while
you were speaking by the way that's why
I was like why is he putting that up
right now so's call uh Harris's uh 30
second rebuttal uh Jamie let's go with
your rebuttal 30 seconds please M got
interrupted anyway your [__] because I
had to I had to correct you for for
being idiotic something that was talking
about what you were being saying on
screen yeah 1 seconds Jamie we're so
professional shut I'm
kidding the basic point is that we are
talking about business here we are
talking about a business model and we
are talking I'm sorry but Amazon Prime
isn't just about Amazon Prime it's also
about MGM Plus thank you Jamie that was
wonderful that was
AB
mg got interrupted it's next topic yeah
desperately want subscribers no no I'm
sorry you you're just wrong the business
model screams
serious financially screams serious and
that's it's just how
though okay so who's ready for the next
question
both of you ready for the next question
all right so we will start with Jamie
this time around so this question is for
both of
[Music]
you I did a
poll let's get the results of the poll I
did a poll and I said this does the show
TV show rather than movie show a lack of
confidence 9% of people said
yes 9 % people said no so most people
agree
with Jay I
[Laughter]
think yeah okay all righty
so so I I have no
confidence anyway yeah it's so let's go
on to the next question um with so much
time passing since SGU was cancelled
only has a only a series that can World
build make sense doesn't
it since suu was already cancelled don't
we have to go back into uh you know
World building
mode Jamie please
start after nearly 15 years and it
probably will be 15 or even more by the
time anything reaches our screens too
much time has gone by and a universe
that was too big to begin with we have a
a franchise that was stretched over two
universes or two sorry two galaxies and
Beyond with the destiny we have
several you know loose threads still
that need to be resolved like where is
the Atlantis the destiny Etc a two-hour
movie cannot scratch the surface of
where the universe is now a 2hour movie
cannot tell anything more than really
well it's two episodes isn't it
basically it's a very short story the
only way for me it would work is if it's
a standalone movie I.E doesn't really
tell us anything about what's going on
in the universe and that will not
satisfy viewers after this long a wait
we desperately want so many of these
questions answered and a two-hour film
just can't do it a two-hour film can
tell us one story it can give us a
snippet it can maybe tease us with a few
things but that's all they can do now if
it's going to be followed up by a season
of something straight away okay but if
the movie bombs it won't be at the end
of the day this could be all we end up
getting there are rumors bouncing around
Amazon actually aren't intending to do a
season straight away that they're
intended to do a Trilogy of movies and
then maybe it'll return to TV so we're
not going to get any of those questions
answered will any fan accept that or
will they end up losing their [__] and
just demanding the series that we should
have got in the first place anyway a
Series has the opportunity to answer the
questions we desperately want to answer
a film can't all right Harris Let's get
your response
here you can World build in a two-hour
film more than you can just look at Lord
of the Rings look at Lord of the Rings
or Star Wars literally anything you can
do in that you're joking if you think a
series can not World build like a movie
can that's that's an utter just joke
whether it's modern day old day or what
like two hours is all you need to World
build if you're making something quality
and doing it with intent and Poise and
actually know what you want to make know
the product know the art that you are
making two hours is all you need it's
more than
necessary plus oh NE next glasses sorry
they want me to wear glasses
[Laughter]
uh
there or should we get a rebuttal it
sound like we need to rebuttal is it
rebuttal time no I completely lost my
train of thought but well while you
gather your your train of thought I'll g
go back to Jay for his rebuttal to your
remarks so far before you got distracted
with your eyeballs again Lord of the
Rings got mentioned all right now yeah
okay Lord of the Rings was a three-hour
movie if you really think though the one
book was nine hours um so yeah okay if
we got three three hour movies telling
one specific story remembering the Lord
of the Rings was really just telling one
story about them you know throwing a
ring into the volcano and there's a lots
of stuff going on around it fair enough
but it was one
story I want more than that I want more
than just one story I want an
entire universe and they you can't do
that in two hours and we're not going to
get three-hour movie the scale Star Wars
are we in rebuttal phase or not can I
yell back or Star Wars Star Wars tell
Mar Wayne more story on the TV series by
the way what go on Star Wars okay so
rebuttal back to uh Harris for 30
seconds all right now that the brain's
back on track
uh like I love your brother buddy but
that none of that made sense at all
literally Lord of the Rings does it's
it's three separate stories three
separate books within three separate
movies each one is not it's not one book
that's nine hours long there's not one
movie that's nine hours long this isn't
Kill Bill volume one and two put
together this is Lord of the Rings one
two three Fellowship Two
Towers
ring alrighty thank you for that
rebuttal Jamie you get 30 seconds
rebuttal and go what
no hell no what the hell was that that
that
was I talked over most of it you that
that was literally triple or quadruple
the amount of of time I got yeah but
whose channel is it so thank you stormy
well done the check is in the mail sir
um go on go on haris finish your
thoughts sir I think that proved my
point he's too scared to actually let me
have any time in next topic and thank
you Jamie for your
autal that was wonderful I love that so
we're down to the last uh debate topic
and then we go into the lightning round
questions um we'll start with Harris
this time we're going to invite Matthew
in again though oh do we have to invite
Matthew in does he have another poll
Matthew will have an another po yet oh
my god oh he remembered to use the thing
yes I used the Stinger this time so we I
did a poll 33 people voted in this poll
and it was quite evenly spit for the
first like 30 seconds um I said Can a
movie tie up S you just as well as a TV
show it was 50/50
pretty much bang on and then it went to
like 7030 but now it's settled finally
it's 48% say yes so 48% of people think
that SGU movie can work just as well as
a TV series but 52% of people say no so
they
win yeah confused for a second well
there we
go so this is the fourth uh debate topic
uh then we'll move into the lightning
round questions this will we will start
with Harris on this one um the question
for both of you is if the movie bombs if
if it just goes Splat Kut nut
off it kills the franchise so it's not
so it's too high of a risk financially
is that true or false Harris please
expand one way or another the film is
being made to make a series like whether
it's a Trilogy of films a singular film
or or whatever A series is coming that
that is pretty undoubted if the movie
bombs which it shouldn't bomb too much
if all of us are going to support it one
way or another if it bombs that means
it's not making its money back
necessarily so that doesn't necessarily
mean it's it's truly bombing if it's a
$75 million movie it might make $ 8590
million and that's a technical bomb
because of marketing still making its
budget back technically all that being
said if it does if that happens and I
don't think any of us are going to let
that happen I I I really strong I I
don't think that we would let that
happen but if it were to happen doesn't
that just make MGM plus happy because if
Amazon Prime is so much more than just
Amazon Prime and MGM plus is such a big
part of Amazon Prime
that'd be the perfect lowbudget thing
it's exactly what they want it's exactly
what they've been asking for they're not
going to get that $10 million an episode
budget they might get a four five three
four five million dollar episode kind of
budget what is that is that Michael Duca
isn't that the guy that runs MGM whoever
the MGM guy is he'd be excited he'd be
very excited because it puts it back
into his Rink one way or another they
don't want Star to go away and it's it's
kind of a franchise that if they don't
make something that IP will go out into
the ether someone has to come buy it so
one way or another they're going to give
us something and that something is going
to end up being a series it just takes a
second sometimes okay
Jamie your position sir I'm just going
to scrap everything I was going to say
because that was just
an Dil Dil sir Dil um with with
respect so what you basically the basic
argument is let's do a movie because it
doesn't matter if it bombs we'll get the
series we want anyway so just don't take
the risk don't spend hundred million and
just give us the series that they were
going to do anyway that is basically
your argument and okay let's just throw
the movie away then let's just not
bother with it because they want to do
the series anyway so great we'll just do
the series the series makes way more
sense financially it w it makes way more
sense because it's what the fans
want Cinema is in flux at the moment and
it there is a massive risk with going to
the cinema with anything at the moment
and at the end of the day a franchise
like Stargate is an unknown they can do
as
much metadata Etc as they like it's an
unknown we don't know if people are
going to go to the cinema to watch us or
not but they will watch it on Stargate
and on Amazon Prime and mm plus we know
this because sg1 is in the top 10 for
Amazon every week sg1 they people are
already watching it and they will watch
a new series we don't know if they will
watch a movie and that is just the
simple truth of and like you just said
if it bombs they'll do a series anyway
so just don't bother don't risk it do
the
series I rest my case and thank you
Harris for making my point for
me all right Harris do you have a 30
second reut
sir I'll
interrupt uh the the only thing that
they would be risking is more success
for
Stargate that's it that that's the only
thing they're risking I'm not sure you
understand how risk
Works a series does not do what if
you're going to go spend a bunch of
money on a series and not focus on an
actual story
a movie allows you to focus on a a story
and have something pivotal and succinct
to build upon all righty Harris thank
you very much for your 30 second
rebuttal we will now go to Jay for his
30 second rebuttal
go Harris's face just says everything
look at that look at that face he knows
he knows he's lost he's I know you don't
allow me time to get in there if I would
have had my last topic your last your
whole point right then would have made a
single look of sense but I was given
one4 of the time in the third
question look tiny little violin there
look
tiny I I'm from Texas I'm playing
[__] celebrate I thank
you and thank you Jamie for your
rebuttal that was wonderful
so that was such such good time manag
good skills there Lads such good time
man love
this and and and did uh did Matt have
some uh demographics and some metrics
for us to uh look at gives us a thumbs
up well yes I
[Music]
did I asked will a movie Kill the
franchise if it bombs do you agree with
Harris or
Jay everyone agreed with Jay um 32% of
people agreed with Harris um
68% with Jay so sorry
Harris man man I'm telling you I love
that hat Matt that hat ruled that was
just awesome all right so the real
question is we have Jay with his his
position we also have Harris with his
position but the question is why should
you pay attention to either of these
guys I mean what do we know we're just a
bunch of Schmucks on Sunday morning
yapping about fandm right which is very
very dangerous so this lightning round
should help cement should help cement
the relative positions and authority of
our two
participants so we we've got some some
fandom
questions questions about
fandom and um which one of you is the
Star Wars fan
primarily that would be Harris correct
couldn't tell you and and I think Jay
you're the mostly the Star Trek fan is
that correct yes I'm the trecky I I like
the good Sci-Fi yeah okay so I will ask
you the other opposite questions all
questions include film television video
games Books and
Comics for the questions correct uh
answer for any of the questions is one
point bonus question is worth two points
the mega nerd questions are worth three
points and the ultra nerd question is
five points and should there be a tie
there will be a tiebreaker question
okay so we'll start with Jamie Jamie
where was Han Solo born don't give a
[__]
corellia so let's just reward that
to
Harris where is James T Kirk
Bor uh no uh so Harris here's your
question where was where was Will rker
born
what Earth uh you got to be more uh you
gota you got to get down to the town
man the T I just gave you a planet and
got a qu got the answer right last
question what what are the rules
here well I could have just said the
Milky Way for oh no it's actually I
could have just said a galaxy far away
and won that well no that's not you got
to at least give me a planet I gave you
a planet I gave you the exact same
answer I got last time and and it got me
a polian and say where are you from and
you say Earth you're getting arrested
well he's he's from Europe the UK he's
not no well did you want to take a stab
at it there uh Jamie I thought it was
San Francisco I have to admit but wrong
on both counts he was born in Valdes
Alaska he often bragged about how he was
from Alaska ah okay all right so that's
nobody that's a feel like I should get
half a point so remember this is for how
why you should trust the authority with
any of these Lads and voting an opinion
on
anything uh so Harris back to you where
was Leonard McCoy
born I I can't say Earth
no oh the things I know this all this
information is is in the is in the works
of Star Trek where was which I've never
seen by the way literally the only Star
Trek I've ever seen are the new three
movies
but I'm going to
say McCoy that's the doctor guy uh yes
he is the doctor guy he doesn't Engles
Jackson doesn't he so I'm I'm gonna say
no Hees oh my [__] god I've never
seen Star Trek the original anything
I've seen three movies okay I'm gonna
say Kansas for shits and giggles Kansas
that is so wrong no but was Bible Belt
wasn't he isn't he like Atlanta he was
born in Atlanta Georgia he doesn't get
that point I'm just GNA say
Georgia it was mentioned in the chat so
therefore I gotta disqualify
that um you've turned the chat off
right uhuh you cheat okay so well I
haven't it hasn't helped me I knew it
was sort of middle of America but I
wasn't sure I wouldn't have got Atlanta
to he was definitely from the south
all right Harris you get a you get a the
Star Trek bonus question where did McCoy
attend Medical
School these are some serious questions
storming for someone
never can I ask if it is a college that
I would be familiar with in 21st century
United States yes okay uh
Stanford wrong okay would you like to
take a stab at it there
Atlanta
University I thought he went to starle
Academy I thought he got his medical at
starle Academy University Mississippi of
course he did he went to miss yeah of
course he went to miss why is he on a
spaceship then like what I know people
from Old Miss I went to a wedding in Old
Miss that a nobody from Old Miss belongs
on a spaceship I love them though
they're fun but all right Jamie Star
Wars question why where was was Admiral
abbar born what planet you just need to
give me the plan so obsessed with where
people were born um it gets better or
worse depending everything happens on
Tatooine on Star Wars would you like
there we go so Harris gets a point
finally now we get to the stuff that I
actually know I was still doing just as
well as you and the stuff that you knew
come on okay so Harris baby what is that
first name
Admiral no uh
Billy Stephen marus I've read it and
it's not one that I'm gonna be able to
pull out of my ass what what is
it gu g i a l guile akar I was just
gonna say guile I was just gonna say I
tip of my tongue that
was okay so now we've gone into the mega
nerd question you've really got to prove
your um your nerdom your your your your
um your your stripes on your shoulders
this is what's going to
uh I don't even know what divide the the
the know- it alls from the
bullshitters where did tree beard hold
the int moot in The Two
Towers what where did hold the int moot
that was in The Two
Towers in his hand well no it's tree his
tree branch he held it by a tree branch
right outside of Eisen guard nope Sarah
on the way to Eisen guard
walk it was do you guys do you guys give
up well he's literally walking towards
eisenhard but there was the inm where he
gathered all the
trees oh okay in the woods yeah in the
forest
surrounding let's call that a zero for
both players was D Dingle D
Dingle D Dingle I should know that the
Rings 30 years
ago okay so this is a Stargate question
so this you guys should get hopefully
holy but i' I've got my doubts man if
you didn't get D Dingle I don't think
where somebody was born I'm going to fly
to America and kill
you okay so
the first one the first question goes to
Jamie okay how many doctorates did
Daniel Jackson
Hold oh oh good question how many
doctorates
yes
three three is correct that was my
answer to damn all right so the next
Mega nerd question goes to Harris what
felds other than archaeology did Daniel
Jackson hold a
PhD other than
archaeology uhds do he
hold he had one in history right or like
a specific type of History I have to
have your entire question your entire
answer excuse
me
I don't have degree titles off the top
of my head uh I moved to California I
didn't finish those
um the
history no they would anthropology and
philology anthropology and philology
theology is the uh the history of
languages and the application in in
relationship of languages not just not
just so that
beo okay so
um jam since you got one question of the
mega nerd thread you will get the ultra
nerd
question and then if there's a tie we'll
go to the
tiebreaker what two colleges did Daniel
Jackson attend Jamie what two colleges
did Daniel Jackson
attend right I'm trying to remember
where he went back to meet
the
woman
Harvard Harvard and
something by the way uh from the uh chat
room Samantha Carter went to the United
States Air Force Academy yeah and I
think she went to MIT as well didn't she
but um
Harvard and somewhere else Harvard and
Stanford uh he went to the only of all
the great schools in California you
missed the one he went to which was UCLA
and then he also that's where he Chicago
and then he did University of Chicago
Oriental Institute was it UCLA he went
to when he met up with his ex then was
it
right
so so far
so far let's see Harris has got
[Music]
one
two but then Jamie pulled out a mega
nerd question so he got one two three
the easiest of all the mega nerd
questions so do you want the tiebreaker
question Just For the Glory of it yeah
when it gets the tiebreaker then come on
because we okay so this is the last
question and then we'll have some sort
of decision here what was the title of
Daniel Jackson's lecture where he
disgraced himself and met Catherine
Langford what was the title of the
lecture oh uh it much to do the ancient
alien and oh man title of the
lecture is there a lunch or
something for all the beans the the
pyramids were Landing ships or something
for aliens but that was it was something
like that nope Harris do you have an
answer
that's
impossible it it it wasn't that they
were landing on the pyramids because
that was part of like the meat of the uh
thing he was talking about the it was
titled something
about um um just just us like human
beings being
um we I guess we were helped along WR
side Evolution right I don't know
exactly what the title was of course
but the title The Old Kingdom in fourth
dnasty Old Kingdom in the fourth Dynasty
that's what dragged out Katherine
Langford from her
Roost so let's uh tally up Harris had
one I
won on the one that should have been
like one point question I think the
pointing system was D Harris got the
entire thing
was Harris got two questions Jamie got
one Mega nerd question so Jamie wins
this contest three I'm
kidding three points to two
congratulations Jamie and this hopefully
will inform our audience who you should
put your faith into concerning our
idiotic
opinions concerning
Amon can we do one of these rounds about
actually like Hollywood and and the way
the the workings actually happen around
here no because you'll win well that's
the
point I want my authority so you
know stick my ass so in what we used to
do when we uh close about this whole
show and I guess we've been almost an
hour bring Matt in and see if he's got
anything else to oh yeah I'm sure mattt
has the metrics for us and then we can
have a we can have a bit of a fourway
for five minutes oh wow I do not I do
not all right anything no I have nothing
I was just swiping you away into
wherever you needed to
be hi everyone hey
Matt someone just said Jay's the Joe
Biden the quizes and I saw that thank
you for that appreciate it p a
compliment no I don't think he is um
those questions was
ridiculously difficult yes they were
that's why they were that's why they
were Mega ND well except the first mega
nerd question that was easier than where
Han Solo was born Jamie didn't get it
yeah he did that's the one he
got to have
seen something this in the presidential
you won the ailia question well no no
I'm saying the first meaner question was
easier than the Cilia question oh the
two Tower Dingle it was easier than all
the where the where the people live
questions all I'm saying in the
presidential debate when we do this
format in future we'll try and be a bit
Slicker for one but for two I I can't
believe I only called Harris an idiot
like four times and I didn't
get it's not nothing presidential
election I've ever seen um I mean I've
seen a presidential election
like debate that ends in a quiz about
[__] Lord of the
Ring hey we did Cover Daniel Jackson in
you know in pretty good detail yeah yeah
we did so Mr Trump where where were the
tree
people Eisen guard oh that's just lost
you the state of Mississippi you
idiot Jay lost but officially won yes I
did I wasn't just
that a residential
debate yeah yeah um I I I think I won
the debate though I won the important
bit but I you didn't let me answer one
of the actual questions though I I've
been watching a lot of the Donald Trump
you kept cutting Harris off so bad all
the time I
literally I was being
respectful well you shouldn't have done
this was this was a debate you're
supposed to like try and stand your
corner and stuff and yeah but I'm leol
Douglas style I ain't all this new age
BS I'm I if you're going to have a
conversation you got to have a
conversation just a second if we're if
we're debating and no I think I'm the
the one that needs to I what I say is
more important than what Harris thinks
just isn't because he lost the debate
and I'll unmute him now sorry what we
you
saying oh I was going to say what did we
all watch this uh
week
um I have actually been loving Paramount
Plus at the moment and I've been
watching slow horses on
apple and watching um the Tulsa King on
um Paramount I've not watched a lot of
sci-fi this week but I tell you what the
Tulsa King is brilliant really really
good so um I'm loving that uh Ryan says
Harris he so did we deer and half the
other
people lost lost lost
and's let's settle this let's settle
this propl let's do a poll yeah how much
did Jamie win by
that's um was it the on this channel is
already rigged but this channel rigged I
allow you here I mean it's like you were
invited case Point J Jay you're not
gonna like
[Laughter]
this oh God I think if you behave like a
let's wait for let's wait for the votes
to come in and it settles but you're not
gonna like
it all I'm saying is guys you have to
vote do you actually want a movie first
or a series first that's all I'm saying
you're not voting for everything I've
said in the last 90 seconds would I've
been mean to
Harris forget that forget I did that of
every single question and then the
rebuttal yeah oh hey thanks sci-fi Quest
that's awesome thank you so much for the
contribution sir and there was a couple
of other contributions as well thank you
so much but we were having too much fun
to read them but um I do have several do
I work for work for the council I
actually have stuff in my home that I
probably
shouldn't don't tell anyone ra him not
[Music]
me if you guys haven't uh watched watch
it um lessons in
chemistry caught up with that this week
excellent excellent with Bri lson just
excellent show it's not SciFi really
really wants to watch that but good I
also caught up with the morning show
also not well there is a rocket thing in
there it's really not sci-fi my wife is
watching that right now and I said I
wanted to watch it a few months ago I
started in my Stargate re binge went
through the movie SG won Atlantis and
finished up Universe where they bundled
everybody
up into cocoons except for por Eli which
has got a slop around the ship and if
you believe the comics he reawakens
three atlantans that's hidden someplace
on the ship and they ignore him they set
out the repair robots and they all scut
all anyway I finish that and the other
there's another
show um also not sci-fi but Mark rufalo
and Hugh Lori all the we cannot see is
that out it's very
serious very serious lot of laughs in
that
no
no it's about it's about the um Nazis um
in a um in France doing Nazi [__] and
hunting down somebody hunting down a
jewel that supposedly has mystical
Powers but it is
in glor it reminds me of in glorious
bastards it's on that kind of raw level
and excellent also kind of reminds me a
little bit of the man in the High Castle
Another World
War post war war II uh series it's just
do yourselves a favor all the light we
cannot
see very very good very very good yeah I
seen I I started watching Firefly again
this week I have to admit which was my I
did a video talking about Firefly so
even though I only watched it about a
month ago I've watched it again binged
it in two days um and I've started
watching For All Mankind which is
actually excellent um again heavy and
you have to you have to keep switched on
I was doing it while working which is
wasn't a good idea um because I then had
to stop it and turn it off and have to
work out to watch it again because I I
missed so much but you have to watch it
properly but um yeah it's excellent For
All Mankind I love apple plus I think
apple plus is great does doesn't the new
uh season of For All Mankind start next
week week after next why I started
watching it and also apple plus coming
in is that um that monik TV series which
is coming I watch the trailer about
talked about that with sci-fi Quest
yesterday I can't wait we're doing a
live about it tomorrow come say howdy
it's gonna be epic I will I will pop
over if I can say um but yeah it's it's
going to be epic I think that series
it's going to be really good off the
hook as you as you might say Harris or
something off the hook something like
that I don't I don't garly
bro it's aome
blood I I call blood a lot don't know
why also uh Harris has some
announcements for his uh Channel if we
could Harris you want to pimp it out a
little bit for us let's do it I'll talk
about what I was watching later in a
second or
whatever am I supposed to interrupt this
as
well interrup with what Harris was
watching yeah okay okay just true just
true uh so we're changing the M cubed
the third cube of the M from movie money
Mary Jane as much as I love my Greenery
it it makes it a little harder for some
people to click and and might be a
little uh little out there for some
folks
so we're making a little more accessible
it's now movies money
music so come on we're we're going to be
uh working on a new format of videos for
both movies and music we'll apply it to
money whenever the time uh is right of
course but we got a new format gonna be
like eight 12 minute videos typically
and we're gonna hopefully try to get
them out in the next week or so and it
should be roughly daily
so come say howdy do do all that good
stuff we we'll still be live streaming
Monday Wednesday Friday Wednesdays for
sure all the time uh yeah it's gonna be
a good time so what did you see this
week what did you watch this
week I I I saw three movies in theaters
on
Friday and then I've been all over with
TV as well um I saw the marsh King's
Daughter which is Daisy Ridley from the
new Star Wars movies and Ben melon who
uh he's in everything uh and and that
was really good I didn't really expect
much from it I didn't know what to
expect from it but it was really good it
was kind of like uh a white dude
bastardized Native American uh kind of
like uh thought process living wise and
he's doing this in modern day but living
way out in the wilderness in Alaska kind
of deal uh maybe not Alaska it might
have been like I think it was Alaska
something like that uh and and it's
really interesting he he it's not like
he's truly bastardizing he's taking the
techniques and applying them to how it
fits him he's raised a daughter and the
daughter uh has grown up living in the
woods it's all she's known but he
kidnapped her mother and that's kind of
a whole thing as the daughter figures
that out and they go into modern day
really good uh I wasn't expecting that
much from it but it was really good I
saw Priscilla which I did not like the
Elvis movie when it came out so I was
really hoping Priscilla was going to be
good and it was it it's shot beautifully
it's well acted and it is God awful um
it's I I I I
don't really
SL really slight spoilers I love Sophia
Copa too but this it it was it was a
film that felt like
uh it it was just antagonistic for no
reason uh particularly on Elvis like a
good chunk of the story wasn't even
about Priscilla it was just
Elvis the slight spoilers I tweeted
about it I said 20% of the movie is
essentially Priscilla wanting to meet
Elvis liking Elvis thinking about Elvis
70% of the movie is Priscilla being
pissed off Elvis won't sleep with her
even though she's 14 years old and
shouldn't be an adult relationship
anyway working her way up into adulthood
and then okay well now he finally slept
with me and then 20% I guess the last
10% not 20 is the process of leaving
Elvis it's it's not it it it feels uh
very
[Music]
um just vital for for not like a
particular reason either and and Lisa
Marie Presley or Le I think that was her
name yeah Lisa Marie the daughter before
Priscilla came out she was like this
should not be released in theater she
was asking Sophia Copa to completely
scrap the movie and I really don't see
how Priscilla Presley herself said this
is the movie I want after she was
praising Elvis like oh this was such a
great movie and all this last year and
then this movie completely does the
exact opposite it was weird it was weird
uh that being said I went and saw a
dream scenario after that I was invited
to the Writers Guild Theater so the
wga's theater which was fun
uh but uh that that was that was a a fun
movie that didn't know exactly what it
wanted to be it was either going to be
like a satirical uh psychological thing
or like a a a really weird
um I I don't know dream Nick Cage was
great in it besides that the movie was
funky anyway TV it's that dream scenario
yeah it it was but I really like the
first two acts and then the third act
just kind of it it that's when it stops
being a satirical kind of uh uh fun look
into things it tries to be a little more
fancy and then it completely goes into
like extra satire and it's it it doesn't
really have a consistent tone per se
okay uh tvwise Loki Rick and Morty Uh
crap ois which is the fantasy version of
Rick Rick and Morty uh I've been
watching those but I've also been on
that Paramount plus kick Jamie I I I
watched 1883 and then I watched uh 1923
1883 might be my favorite miniseries
I've ever W watched uh I'm very excited
for the season two of 1923 but 1923 was
good uh little Harrison Ford and Helen
mirin was great let me see what else I
got oh oh speaking of Paramount plus
tonight Taylor Sheridan the guy that
does both of those shows and Tulsa King
and all those others he has law man bass
Reeves coming out tonight which I'm
excited to uh check out the first
African-American law man known in North
America I think uh and besides
that I'm not that I'm not having
that no no Take that off the screen we
don't need that on there no no no uh CNN
Attack on Titan had its series finale
yesterday phenomenal phenomenal Attack
on Titan to send what what is Attack on
Titan run on what what's that from whe
stream it's on Hulu I'm not sure if it's
there in its entirety but it's on a
crunchy rooll in its entirety too uh
okay that's one of those things get one
of those like monthlong subscriptions
then unless you want to watch a bunch of
anime uh which a never a Bad Thing uh
speaking of animated things bringing it
back to sci-fi finishing up my my long
list of things I've been watching this
week the best show on TV right now is
scavengers reain it's I don't I don't
think it's airing in the U uh UK just
yet find a VPN and find a way to watch
it it's the epitome of sci-fi it's it's
it's stripped back it's bare there's
three or four or five kind of characters
going around but none of them really
talk a whole bunch it's not like
non-talking but they really focus on the
world World building and the actual like
sci-fi aspect of the environment that
they're having to deal with in this new
planet that they crash landed on oh it's
it's amazing uh it's anime is it anime
it's not anime but it's animated it's
kind of got an anime style to it but
it's not uh animated in the same style
where it's like fast-paced and things
and Lines Moving like this it's very
slow and deliberate but it has more of
that anime look to it gotcha hey hey
Matt what did you watch this
week Dr
Walking Dead no I've literally not
watched anything at all I still have to
watch Loki I'm G to watch it after this
I've been editing that's all I've been
doing I've just been doing
editing um you've actually been doing
work s
TR that video you've done um calling for
Brad Wright is actually is actually
beautifully edited I know it took you
about a week to do which we don't do a
video like we do like videos a week I
had two days off work so I took those
two days to make a video I've actually
made another one as well which is going
up on
Friday
um yeah that's what I've been doing yeah
there there's there's the link to my
channel if you want to go and
subscribe yeah go subscribe so I've
actually got a little bit of news a
little bit of news uh yes this is um
back during Co I started this uh YouTube
channel called srack excuse not
Sidetrack [__] what I'm talking about
side Works side Works where I was bored
out of my mind and I do crazy little
experiments you could do in your kitchen
kitchen sinks but also started a channel
just because I loved it was uh
revitalizing a lot of old radio show
sci-fi and horror radio shows and I'll
put a link in the uh chat box here for
it it's uh it's a professor cringe hosts
nigh house and right now I've got uh
original um episodes of uh Dracula or
not Dracula excuse me Dracula's next
I've got
Frankenstein and I've got uh the one
I've just posted was the Lost Tomb the
Lost Tomb and I've also got the Strange
Case of Dr Jackal and Mr Hy Dr Jackal Mr
Hy goes for 10
hours 10 hours Frankenstein's two and a
half hours and the lost Tom is a quick
one uh only an hour and five minutes so
yes I'm Professor cringe I'm no longer
I'm I may do you know uh side works in
the future but that doing the
experiments and figuring those out and
getting them right and all the shots it
takes it's just a lot of work and you
know we're not in coid time now and I
don't have a lot of time to burn but I
do do love always love these old sci-fi
in hard radio shows and the the writing
is still amazing the acting is still
amazing and these old some of them over
are approaching a hundred years old and
they're still amazing so uh if you would
just go uh subscribe to that and I'd be
most appreciative please love of God
subscribe modern day RCA that's right
genuinely one of my favorite videos ever
is stormmy playing with hydrogen because
I spent the whole video going it's going
to explode it's going to explode and he
doesn't explode but the tension is is
fascinating you didn't like the one
where I had I showed all the organisms
living in the swamp water with a laser
yeah that was fine but the hydrogen one
was better
because everybody Lov the hydrogen
one um but yes this is g to sound wrong
right but let me finish the video that
you put on with the radio stuff is
excellent for going to sleep to um but
not because it's boring it's just
because it's it's you know like thing
because you want to have some something
in the background and you're listening
to it and then so I've um set it up and
then after the next night I've had to go
back and find out where I was with it so
I can listen to it again but um I loved
it for that I think they're really good
thank you listening to a couple so um
there and I've shared it on the
Community page this afternoon and I
shared it on our Facebook group so guys
go check it out and have a listen uh
Matt's video Brad was shared everywhere
as well go again go check it out B
everybody that am yeah it was brilliant
go show love to everyone's Channel
except for Harris um if if you are
subscribe to Harris please
unsubscribe um and uh basically block
him I think would be for the best
depending on what Matt says Now Matt
how's the poll
going po right let's have a look see
where we're at it was 50/50 for like
forever and then everyone in the
comments was like
Jay's creating accounts Jay's creating
accounts now it's like 54% to
Jay but everyone subscribe to
Harris when when we first did it it
literally just went Harris and like
30% no I think I think we can yeah
Harris was not
robbed he wasn't robbed he just he
didn't Harris honestly now now we've
moved on from the thing what would you
honestly want to see a serus or a movie
first oh a movie like a th% I I think if
you're actually thinking about it like
as an executive as someone who wants to
see the franchise succeed a movie makes
way more sense I I like literally I I
love I love everything you said and a
series makes sense but it doesn't make
sense more so than a movie to bring new
audiences everybody that oh
god oh dear lord who said that Ryan [__]
man that was good I love that vote
Ryan Ryan got a future political writing
he really
does I went I'm afraid but
um yeah a movie can come later a series
just makes more sense to me and it's
less I don't think it can look at Ahsoka
and all the Mandalorian stuff are you
excited for the air of the Empire movie
now oh no don't care you have well all
of the stuff that the Mandalorian and
Ahsoka and book of Boba Fett all this is
supposed to lead to an ingame level
movie and that's like thraw and all that
and and that's what happens whenever I
guess it just
gets the the hard part with the series
is it's years of stuff that's years of
people to come up with different ideas
that's years of people to come up with a
movie you have a solidified something
that you're working with and that as
questions and those questions can be
answered in that series then that that
gives it us a sync something to follow
instead of just instead if we don't have
a movie your first four episodes
essentially have to be about all right
so where are we what's going on what are
we gonna get going on now it it it makes
it much much harder where a movie
streamlines it it just streamlines it
one the one question I threw in I'm
sorry one sec the one question I threw
in was about confidence um because I
knew I was weak on that I didn't have an
answer for that and at the end of the
day if Amazon in do a movie that shows
they have massive confidence in the way
more confence exciting that
would you know talking about the
confidence issue we've discussed this
before I mean Stargate is one of the
great franchises you know one movie
right three you know well if you count
you know some of the other there's some
offshoot movies there was three series
there was one web series Oodles of books
and comic books and other you know I
mean it's and it's stayed around I mean
here we are are talking about it decades
later you know and and as a oh there we
go yeah and wasn't there a a trading
card game for Stargate at one point in
time yep wasn't there that came out a
couple years ago but you from a fan me
as a fan I just wish they'd make
something you know I mean I'm dying for
anything you know whether it's movie
series I I'll I'll I'll love anything
but I'd rather have a series because
it's more screen time I get
my okay my biggest thought after that
and I think timekeepers is really
solidifying the movie to me is if they
actually the series is safe timekeepers
was
safe that's what I'm worried about I do
not want another effing timekeepers that
literally that's the most annoying video
game I've played in possibly the last 10
years like it I I don't know it's just
that's not how it should that that's not
how a game should be designed and that's
not how we as a fandom should be hyped
back up to go into a world that's been
gone for so long literally that entire
opening animation with the x302 over
Antarctica that would have been a better
game give me give me an hour and a half
game about that and I would have rather
played that than than the timekeeper
game surprised because I saw your um
review and you seem to enjoy it I mean I
I mean I mean if ioke a joint something
playing it I'm going to make sure I have
a little bit of fun but like it it it
was the most frustrating I was I mean it
was you can see in the review I'm
frustrated as hell the entire time
there's not a second that I'm not
frustrated in that en you die and you
just go damn
it madebe me laugh it just that's what
I'm worried about with the series is
like it are they gonna do it's a good
game if you play it properly there is no
playing that property that Pro properly
should have been on a phone game not
someone trying to put it on Steam and
sell you it for $25 $30 that game is not
worth $25 $30 that game's not worth
$2 I'm sorry that's just what it
is something uh that's just what I'm
worried about with the series I I feel
like they end up doing it because it's
safer and then the safer it becomes the
more guard rails you get up against it
the less risk you take the more I mean
just for another fun Star Wars reference
there are no guard rails anywhere in the
Death Star there are no guard rails
anywhere in those big old engine rooms
it keeps a little excitement going it
lets people fall off the side and let
you jump back up with your lightsabers
and all that obviously we're not doing
that but it's a good analogy in the
sense like we don't want those guard
rails up we want something we we want
these creators to take risk with the
property that we love and we want to see
it move forward in creative ways not
safe boring ways that we've
seen 18 years worth of stuff
before
what do we want to debate next because I
I really enjoyed this format we'll get a
bit better at doing
it you debate can we call it a mass
debate yes
yes doing it on mass and yeah um so I
mean I suggested Star Trek versus Star
Wars which is the which which is better
basically because I to my wife once and
she threatened to throw me at the
house um that's difficult because Star
Wars technically isn't sci-fi so one way
or another the Sci-Fi oriented aspect of
things is gonna put it that can be that
can be part of the um argument you can
make I would argue that yes okay it's
sci-fi fantasy but it's still
sci-fi
and I mean but there are there I think
there are loads of arguments you can
make um it's just just yeah what do we
what do you fancy arguing because this
is a fun format to do it stormy I think
something with Lord of the Rings might
be fun for you to try to argue we can
argue have have an an argument of yes or
no just that yes or no and you just got
you just got to argue for
yes right let's do
it you argue for yes try and be creative
with it you've got to argue for no
whatever the question is no's always
your answer is that what you're saying
no no the the debate is yes or no and
that's it and you just got a debate yes
or no I kind of like that idea I kind of
like it but you've gotta be creative
with it and you've got to somehow get
the vote Yes or No the H sexy yes I
could take
maybe um but plug's not allowed for the
love of God no hey I didn't it yeah but
he put the two pound on it so
acting
he put two never mind I was going to
make it never mind well what else can we
discuss I put a pound on it exactly yeah
just and anything you want to say out
loud if you do it as a super I have no
damn
Choice um so I should open the
floodgates but um but no I yeah I've I
don't know about you guys but I've loved
doing it this way I think it's been
really fun we'll get better at doing all
the flippy around and doing the the
production side of things and
remembering that we do an opening
statement
stormy okay
fine and don't forget my polls
the um but there no that was a lot of
fun and um I really really loved it and
and Harris I'm sorry you're not an idiot
you're a very bright young man well
depends on the day or the minute of the
day and you almost had me once or
twice and then I was cut
off you know I just enjoyed writing off
these nerd questions that was the
highlight for me we know you did and and
you enjoyed us staring at the screen
like what the [__] is he asking what
where's it going from uh the
South number what you impressed by my
Earth comment multiple times but I I
tried yeah yeah and ironically most of
the Daniel Jackson's can't comments came
from the novelization of
St did you purposely dress as a referee
today okay yes I did um the referees
don't dress like this you on about you
look like a referee like Stripes I don't
black um Ryan Leman where was I born
there you go secular one keywok versus
fings they're the same thing so that
would just be one big fluffy
battle the furlings left the Milky Way
and moved to a galaxy far far away and
just slowly devolved over time okay so
so here here's a question I couldn't get
answered uh didn't make it into the
questions but how many
galaxies did Destiny go through during
the uh
show 32 is that we witnessed we saw it
in the um sequence where um rush says
we've gone way way right in the first
episode have we gone into another is
that the Milky Way no and then and it's
32 it is 32 3 38 actually sorry 38
definitive answer and I
said there is a proper answer you can
count them as the As and then you see
roughly where they are but they then
went through two others to
40 and the the the one where they left
Eli Eli was heading to the 40 first
Galaxy is that
correct they went two more yeah so
actually no it's 30 no it isn't is it's
40 will be the next one because they
were in the 38th Galaxy and then they
traveled to the 39th didn't they yeah
and then they're on their
way we see three galaxies in SG do
we I don't
know I don't know it's either 40 or or
or or
[Music]
39 but 38 is the hot
bed Destiny it should be 42 the answer
should be 42 now destiny was in the
Milky Way when they first boarded is
that
correct uh yes LA from Earth right right
right laun from 50 million years ago
yeah it had to be in that sphere of
gates that were within travel that were
travelable that were connectable to
Destiny so I'm guessing you had to be uh
mil but that's where the Ancients were
based at the time that was they settled
on Earth
first second sorry they didn't they
settled in Earth second they they landed
on one planet I forget the name of it
and then they traveled to Earth and
that's where they sort of established
and then they they spread from aara
thank you um and and then yeah and then
they traveled to
Pegasus then they came
back and they abandoned Destiny because
Ascension
they didn't need it they could just
Ascension over there and have a look and
then it puttered around until Rush found
it yeah or I don't know last ancient
that like everybody else had have send
it around him and he was just like how
the hell do I do this and just ends up
like meditating for another decade or
something and then finally just send or
something who was the last one that was
just kind of turning the lights on and
off for a while you
know who
knows ascending machine that was for the
people that couldn't do it didn't they
the one McKay McKay ended up
superer that was a good episode that
was the the um an just left everything
on in that City just ridiculous health
and safety nightmare right guys one
thing I never understood though sorry
I'll I'll let us go in a minute the they
had the ascendo machine I'm want to call
it the ascendo in Atlantis and that
basically gave everyone the powers to to
to ascend right because it gave him that
knowledge and all all of this stuff
right when O'Neal stuck his head in that
machine and got all of the knowledge of
the Ancients why did he not
Ascend oh God that's a good question
because he has all the knowledge of the
an therefore he knows about Ascension so
why did he not send that is a good point
because it is a spiritual journey as as
well as knowledgeable the the ascendo
machine actually did genetically change
it's a physical change yeah it's a
physical change as well wasn't it so I
mean that's maybe the difference they
were trying to but it didn't did it so
maybe his FR just wasn't up to
it yeah maybe but also I suppose the
thing with what happened to Jack was
that it was so rapid maybe and he just
wasn't so he didn't have time not any
more rapid than um than
but may had physical changes as well um
O'Neal just had the information dumped
in his brain didn't
he but he was changing he was physically
changing his his he was changing because
he was then started talking his brain
start to change I mean the mechanics
changing so yeah that's a very good
point why didn't he
Ascend because it would have been the
end of the
show maybe that's would way wouldn't
because Daniel ascended twice and he
came back
yeah yeah and I think Jack would get
kicked out of the ascended being Club
quicker than Daniel did yeah I think so
um there was um uh on the dial of the
gate video last week there was a bit
where Michael Shanks was on and he was
talking about how there was there was a
joke Brad Wright had passed him script
and it was in the halfway through the
first season when Daniel dies then they
go to the funeral and but Brad only gave
him the the pages from the actual
funeral and then but didn't tell him
anything else so Michael Shanks sat
there the whole flight going I'm going
to die I'm going to die it's my first
proper job this is [__] and I'm just
like yeah that was so prophetic though
because then he goes on to die several
times he wasn't
bothered um but I I thought that was
such a good joke to play on him because
it was so prophetic about how his
character was going to go in the end but
um any he was worried about two things
how he was going to go and if he's going
to get
paid death and taxes death and taxes
right right yeah all right guys well
thank you so much like say really really
enjoyed that something we're going to do
again I think when we um have a topic
that we want to argue hopefully it might
have you know given Amazon a few ideas
you never know
um there has been a little bit of
a update from the last week but it I'll
leave it until next week though because
want to I just want to find out a little
bit more information about what's going
on but
basically there's been more
conversations but I think Bas everything
Amazon at the moment is focused on the
um the strikes and getting this
cancelled which I would be very
surprised if it didn't get
resolved in the next 48 hours or so so
Harris might be able to actually get a
job soon that'd be nice I would love
that come on y'all some please please
also forgot to mention
Harris could play the new the the the
younger uh Daniel
Jackson that would be the only role I
would take if it weren't gonna be Aris
Bach probably the third Sam Jones would
count I'm not recasting anybody so calm
down you can
be fine I'll calm down no recasting does
that make you V on as well no no recast
I'll be Daniel Jackson junior Jr or
junor
yeah the onei Jacks jun j I was thinking
Sam Jones had a son if Daniel Jackson
had a son in the amount of time between
when it left our screens and now the kid
would be like
18 so for him to have a son and you play
that son that just doesn't work how
about if Harris was like a Jedi Jafar
would that work I'll take that any day
Eris Bach
Jaffa
I'm gonna C the force up in this
[__] okay ew back to their original
Galaxy yeah uh Arnold yeah um I believe
it's already filmed isn't it yeah yeah
Michael ke said it's the most fun he hat
on a film set since Birdman which was
the most funny hat on a film set since
Beetlejuice so cool I can't wait for it
it's gonna be cool um but yeah um yeah
and Wednesday Adams isn't in she not the
real Wednesday Adams I can't remember
name let's he's any good but um yeah I
watched Beetle Juice on Monday at the
cinema loved it the original I should
say and it's just it still holds up it's
still such a great show brilliant movie
um and Michael Keaton is just just mad
in it but anyway guys thank you so much
um we will be back next week with one
one I'm I'm kidding I'm kidding I didn't
say that either I was waiting for
it I've already strung this out for a
half an hour you know Jay's got a pee by
this time no I'm good you're are all
that beer you still I need to pee um
thanks guys say byebye everybody good
night everybody thank you for joining
us stretch it out a little bit because I
can't find the end in sequency bit thank
you
[Music]
adio